es sind bilder wie aus einem hollywood
film die uns gerade erreichen
mitarbeiter im weißen haus in
schutzkleidung desinfizieren die
presseräume im weißen haus die angst vor
dem virus scheint immer größer zu werden
jetzt wurde bekannt dass sich der
nächste aus trumps engsten berater
umfeld infiziert hat steven müller fast
täglich steigt die zahl der infizierten
im umkreis von donald trump der selber
an dem virus erkrankt ist die meisten
haben sich wohl im rosengarten des
weißen hauses angesteckt trump gibt sich
aber weiter kämpferisch sagt ich werde
die wahl gewinnen der krone virus
ausblick innerhalb des weißen hauses hat
sich weiter dramatisch vergrößert auf
der einen seite sitzt us präsident
donald trump in den privatgemächern und
hat einen warm twitter sturm abgefeuert
am gestrigen tag auf der anderen seite
ist der west wing normalerweise die
pulsierende kommandozentrale der usa
völlig verwaist es grassiert auch die
angst unter den reportern wie mir ein
journalist mitgeteilt habe es ist
herrscht wirkliche angst nur die
journalisten fürchten dass auch sie
angesteckt werden wie bereits einige
kollegen vor ihnen auch wurde bekannt
dass jeder soldat der den sogenannten
nuclear football jenes portal mit dem us
präsident donald trumps sogar atom
raketen abschießen kann dass dieser
soldat ebenfalls mit dem corona virus
infiziert worden ist angeblich gibt es
auch weitere fälle im pentagon
möglicherweise haben sich die generäle
selbst bei donald trump angesteckt
aufgrund des twitter sturms gibt mehren
sich die stimmen hier in washington dass
der präsident möglicherweise an
nebenwirkungen der eingenommenen
steroide erleiden könnte er nimmt das
steroid dexamethason das möglicherweise
bei einigen patienten zu money führen
kann und es wird hier in washington
bereits immer offener diskutiert dass
der präsident möglicherweise werden
verstand verloren haben könnte mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren